I'm talking about people that drunk and
that right there is why unreal star
Constance Zimmer is nominated for her
very first Emmys she's amazing she plays
the morally challenged tough-as-nails
producer of a bachelor s TV show so
really comes by surprise when she got
all emotional with Kevin Frazier what
would it mean to win an Emmy I mean I'm
making cried I can't
whoa to me it's like the well it's that
thing that you always dream about and
you don't ever expect so you know it
would be life-changing this I think we
love seeing the softer side of Constance
you know we're from shows like entourage
and agents of shield but it's unreal
that's getting a lot of attention this
week in a case of art imitating life
remember Chad's bachelor in paradise
incident unreal did it first the episode
aired on Monday and people definitely
were like alright you've definitely gone
too far because you had a producer slip
a little some type of diuretic into the
food okay it's a horrible thing to do to
anybody and then cut to wake up 24 hours
later and it actually happened on
bachelor in paradise blowing my mind
Constance promises next week's season
finale will be even more explosive and
revealed something else
she's a big Michael Jackson fan but this
we couldn't get over this who also had
up Michael Jackson full-size cutout in
your room
no it was a life-sized doll it got a
little weird boyfriend's would come over
and they're like why do the life-sized
Michael Jackson doll in your bedroom
it's also weirdly fantastic at the same
time okay get this Constance was also in
the front row of Michael Jackson's
infamous Pepsi commercial the one worse
hair caught on fire but she started
crying but she told us she still has the
Pepsi can signed by the Jackson 5 so all
as well
you